these satellite images from a u.s
company show a buildup of russian troops
on the border with ukraine
fields and forests once largely
untouched in russia now covered in
tracks from military vehicles about 15
kilometers from the border with ukraine
[Music]
social media posts from people in the
region are giving more clues about what
is happening on the ground
al jazeera was able to independently
verify this video posted by a truck
driver passing armored russian vehicles
other content includes pictures and
posts from the wives of some russian
military personnel talking about their
husbands activities
the information is being used by
investigative journalists to build a
picture of what is happening in the
region
videos of russian troop movements are
very useful because they allow us to
establish exactly where russian forces
are amassing ahead of any possible
invasion it also gives you a clue to how
prepared they are for the innovation and
any final movements that they're making
to move into position ahead of basically
the day of invasion so the videos coming
from russia have been extremely useful
in establishing exactly what's going on
in the
ground and the online content is making
its way into popular culture one of the
reasons
one of the reasons we know what's going
on with russia's military is social
media because videos of russian troops
massing on ukraine's borders are being
widely disseminated on tick-tock
leading the media to label this conflict
the tick-tock war
the information war is not just being
conducted by governments but on people's
mobile phones
leah harding al jazeera